Aubrey,
Marcus,
welcome to the show.
What's up to him?
Hey Man,
I'm going to shake your hand cause I don't usually do a video.
And here we are in the Shanghai of Texas,
otherwise known as Austin.
I've never seen so many cranes in one place in the United States.
Yeah,
it's thriving.
It is really thriving and I think we're on the cusp of all sorts of fun in the
next couple of years.
I like it.
People whine about it like,
Oh,
you know,
Austin used to be this kind of reminiscing fantasy thing.
I think it's just getting better.
Well I think it's uh,
it's like talking to someone who went to a concert in the early days with any
man.
They're like burning man used to be so cool man.
The 2007 before you got here in 2008,
grateful dead.
I was at their first show.
Now it's so on.
Cool.
So there's,
there's a lot of discussion along those lines about Austin,
but you are one of the people I know best here in Austin.
Yup.
And I'm thrilled to have you in front of the mic.
It gets gradually came out dope,
hang out and have some wine and have some dinner and I know I'm not impressing
anyone with my 45 pound deadlifts and the Ana gym.
You have a lot.
No,
but it's your persistence though to him.
It's the fact that you do it so many times and only do that.
Ooh,
wow,
that's true.
We'll,
last time you saw me in that gym,
I was working on a program from Jersey Gregorich,
the 63 year old former world record holder in Olympic weightlifting doing only
overhead squats.
If I remember crying for like an hour and a half old all day,
let's Tim do it.
No more overhead squat.
So part of the reason I wanted to have you here to have this conversation is
that I feel like you are one of the people who really walks the walk in checking
the boxes of these overlapping spheres of life.
Whether that is body business,
let's just call it balance.
I'm actually barring this bit from a weekend event.
One of my friends went to not too long ago,
but you,
you've done a really good job of integrating those various pieces.
And so this format of this particular podcast is going to be a bit experimental
and jarring maybe,
and it's lack of transitions.
But I want to start with a question.
I was recently asked at a small dinner and the question was posed by a guy named
Michael Hubs,
who's fascinating guy,
very good chef,
organizes dinners around specific topics very often.
So he did one,
I think it was called dinner or dining with death and it was in cooperation with
NPR and it was a facilitated conversation around mortality.
And he's done many of these and had a small dinner with him in La with about six
to eight people and no one really knew any other attendee.
And to break the ice,
he started with this question,
which just opened up the flood gates so that everyone got very vulnerable and
very open very quickly.
And this is it.
So thank you Michael.
When is the last time that you cried tears of joy that you remember?
Oh Man.
[inaudible] that wasn't too long ago.
That's,
that's a,
a more frequent occurrence for me actually.
And as
I've done,
you know,
a lot of work on my life and it hasn't been the external stuff that ever makes
me cry.
Tears of joy.
It's not a big on that success.
It's not something external that happens.
It's really just sitting in a moment.
It can be with the lover that I'm sharing a night with and I'll just start
crying.
And just the experience of enjoying that simple moment or laughing with friends
or,
I mean,
it's actually a rather frequent occurrence and that's one of the best indicators
for me that the path that I'm on is yielding the kind of fruit that I'm really
looking for and looking to forge because I catch myself doing that all the time.
I actually today I had a little informal mentorship with one of my employees and
just as I saw that breakthrough moment,
I saw that moment where,
you know,
I was talking about her working not on her business and not on her career at on
it,
but on her heart and how that,
and she's like,
yeah,
it's a big project.
And I go,
yeah,
it is a big project.
And I saw that light come up and just the tears will come in that moment for me
too.
It's just like,
fuck yeah.
You know,
like I'm,
I'm,
I'm doing what I'm supposed to be doing.
And then just the gratitude for being able to do what I'm supposed to be doing,
it'll just,
it'll come.
Is that something that has always been the case or is that something that has
become more frequent with any kind of trigger or catalyst?
It's uh,
it was very rare.
You know,
I think it was very rare cause I think most of my life I was trying to achieve
something.
I was trying to validate myself externally,
trying to say,
if I get to this point,
then I'll be successful.
Then I'll be,
you know,
living up to my potential,
then I'll be that.
And whether it was in high school for basketball,
like,
Oh,
if I make all state honors,
then I'll be there.
If we make it far in the playoffs and it'll be there.
And it was always this next thing,
but it's never the next thing.
You can keep searching for that next thing.
You're not going to find it until you turn that gaze truly inward.
And as that process has gone,
and I've almost kind of exhausted the external things,
so it's kind of forced me to go internal because when on it was successful in
the external was great then and I still wasn't that happy deeply.
And I was like,
all right,
it's definitely not external.
This is internal.
And that's driven me deeper and deeper inside my heart.
If I look back at my own experience with,
uh,
relationships with people who have unfortunately taking their lives,
it's not the depressing outwardly depressing cases that you would expect.
It's actually very often the people who have a lot of money,
not always,
uh,
certainly.
But it strikes me that for instance,
one of my best friends,
uh,
Andrea in high school,
then two friends later in college,
uh,
seem to have everything going for them.
And of course,
I shouldn't say of course,
but nobody saw these coming and they were,
they all had a good amount of money.
And my theory related to that based on what I see also in people who are from
the outside in very,
very successful,
very,
very wealthy but miserable,
is that for a long time,
for most of life,
if you're fighting for every scrap to get this external validation,
you can envision a day when I have x,
it'll all be great.
And this anxiety,
I feel this fill in the blank that I feel will go away and then it doesn't go
away.
And so then at that point,
if you've checked the boxes,
it seems like you can lose hope or if you grow up rich and you realize it does
not in fact as a panacea soldier prompts.
So my question then,
walk us through how you shifted your gaze to be more internal.
Because I've,
I've seen that in,
you may have known each other that long.
We've known each other for a while and
I'd love to just hear how you made the decision or how you were forced to look
inward because a lot of people get to a point where the outside world,
third parties would think of them as successful,
but they never shift the gays.
Yeah.
So,
so how did it happen?
It's in combination from like external pressure,
you know,
external pain,
internal pain,
like pain as a motivator to let you know that something is wrong.
And then so that's kind of like your engine light blinking.
And then it's the practices that I've employed that helped me have that
introspection to actually go searching and figure out what it is.
So it's always been a combination of that pain plus the tools to go seek out
where that pain is coming from.
And I was fortunate,
I was given an opportunity to do a vision quest when I was just out of high
school and I was staunch atheist,
zero spirituality.
How did that come?
That was through my father and I had had a lot of issues with my dad,
but he was in a lot of pain himself and that it took an him down,
you know,
to try everything from primal therapy to all kinds of different conventional
methods.
Eventually into psychedelics.
Working with actually with Stan Groff doing holotropic breathing,
doing LSD psychotherapy doing and he found a shaman who worked with silicide
been in the mountains and you know,
where was this?
This was in the mountains in New Mexico and he after high school in that
traditional kind of vision quest kind of idea said,
you know,
you should go experience this because at that point,
he would talk about anything on the fringe of spirituality and I'd grown up here
in Texas and getting washed with religion,
capital r religion.
I was like,
fuck that.
You Know Dad,
like I'm not interested in that.
Like,
I saw the dungeons of the inquisition.
This is bullshit.
You know,
this is bad.
And he's like,
no,
just check it out and see what happens.
It's a vision quest.
And I respected like,
you know,
native American culture enough and traditional culture enough that I was like,
all right,
I'll give it a go.
And I was fucking terrified.
Like,
can you hear us?
Can you explain to people who describe what that vision quest entails?
It's kind of,
it's a traditional rite of passage where typically young man,
but it can be any men goes to find an aspect of themselves that has been hidden.
Some calling,
some of them that they don't know about that they aren't aware of.
And that's certainly what happened.
You know,
I was given a t in the mountains in a very isolated place with a very loving and
warm,
um,
you know,
mushroom Sharmane and she gave me a tea.
And then after a little while I felt my entire body evaporate into geometry.
And then I was like,
oh shit.
Like I got a lot of things wrong.
You know,
like there is something else to this experience.
And that was just this.
I stayed up all night writing and there was thunderstorms and the coyotes
howling.
I Dunno,
they sounded like wolves,
but I'm probably coyotes being in New Mexico and,
and it was this crazy night of just realizing that my whole paradigm at that
point,
it shifted.
I'd realize that I'm not just body and mind.
There's something else that I access,
something that could observe both of those things.
And that's been kind of like the fallback,
you know,
teacher for me and finding the ways then to not just use the medicines but find
ways to get there in other means because that's kind of like a feast.
You can't feast every night.
Finding the other ways to access that identification point.
So you do not have kids as far as I know at this point that you're aware of.
But if I do have any kids out there and you want to claim it,
like we'll talk about that right now.
I'm going a pretty good spot now.
[inaudible]
Dot Com uh,
uh,
when you have,
if and when you have kids,
I'm not sure if that's in the cards,
but if you do,
would you walk them through,
let's just say you was son doesn't necessarily matter son or daughter,
would you,
would you walk them through or introduce them to a rite of passage like that?
Fuck yeah.
Like they're undoubtedly,
how would you structure it?
What do you think it would look like?
Well,
I think as a parent,
as a dad,
you have to kind of get out of the way because part of the vision quest is
getting your kid out of your purview.
Right?
You know,
like allowing them to become their own man.
So I would find someone who is,
you know,
separate enough for me that I wasn't influencing the experience in someone I
trusted.
And you know,
I know a lot of people right now and I'm sure I'll know a lot of people even
even then and talking to,
you know,
maps and talking to her after and talking to those organizations that are
working on the legalization of these as medicines.
I think there's going to be a lot of cool options,
um,
for people to do that completely above board.
And legally by the time I have a kid,
I mean they're targeting 20,
21 for Mgma therapy and psilocybin sometime after that.
So I think there's going to be a lot of options and it's going to become more
common.
And um,
you know,
I'd just send them with someone I really trusted and uh,
allow the process to unfold.
And that's the thing you,
you really don't want to guide it too much.
You want to have the guide and allow the medicine and the,
and nature and everything around them to be the teacher.
I'm sure there are people watching or listening who have had early say,
adolescent or high school or college experiences with psychedelics,
but
viewed them in retrospect is sort of uncontrolled recreational.
So do you think the reason that vision quest stuck with you,
how much of it was the psychedelics versus the ceremony versus the guidance?
I mean,
if you had to try to weight those factors,
how would you,
they're inextricably,
they're inextricable,
right?
You know,
like the experience itself blends together and becomes inseparable.
Like you couldn't take one part and have it all be there.
You know,
it was the trust that I had in the guide because I think one of the big problems
with taking psychedelics haphazardly like,
am I going to die?
Right.
You know,
is this going to,
am I going to,
am I gonna get busted by the cops?
Is this,
is,
this is right environment?
What does that does that person looking at me funny?
You know,
like all of these crazy things come in and can steer it into really squirly
pathways.
But having that steady loving presence available and just being out in the land
and having it and knowing that I was part of a lineage that had done this
thousands of times for many,
many generations,
that what gave me the support system to be able to really let go.
Because I think you can really stay tense and fight,
you know,
fight these experiences and you get stories and reports of people taking
incredibly high doses and they're like still so bound up.
They can't even release into it.
But having a guide that really you trust is absolutely essential because they're
really guiding you through this massive bursting of a cocoon,
you know,
and it's,
it's pretty terrifying on its own.
And having somebody there to help is absolutely essential.
And I only,
I only recommend doing it in that context until you are somewhat of a master
yourself.
Yeah,
agreed.
And definitely get external verification that your masters not,
I've been on youtube and I think I understand as well enough.
I'm a black belt now.
Yeah.
Uh,
I watched triple rainbow three times.
I know what bliss is.
Exactly.
What did you think you wanted it to be when you grew up when you were 1617,
18?
You know,
I think I really,
I was always into history and I was,
I would look at all the great conquering heroes and the great kings and the
great,
the people who had led these big movements.
And I looked around and obviously,
you know,
Kangaskhan was kind of an asshole,
I didn't really want to kill people and that's not the way it's happens anymore.
So really the people leading the movements,
you had politicians,
but they didn't seem like they were quite doing anything that I was interested
in.
And then so you had,
you know,
business leaders and thought leaders and authors.
And so I think I always knew I was going to end up in one of those categories,
either leading an organization or a writing books or speaking or something.
And interestingly,
I doubted myself the whole way because I failed that.
Absolutely everything I tried.
And like what,
what did you try that didn't work out?
Literally everything.
I mean I tried gold mining,
I tried some variety of different online retail from sex toys to skincare to I
tried oil and gas.
I tried like,
well on gas,
like trading site invest like um,
investor relations,
you know,
like trying to convince people to go bet on some wildcat fucking oil wells in
the middle of nowhere.
That never works,
you know,
and I'd get some stock options like this one's going to hit,
never hit nothing.
But now looking back,
I'm grateful because I literally failed at everything that wasn't directly going
to serve my purpose.
And all of those failures,
all the lessons gave me the strength to be able to hold an organization of this
magnitude that I'm holding now.
Like the person that I was then couldn't run on it.
Like I couldn't write the book that I wrote.
I couldn't do the things that I'm doing.
I couldn't have this conversation now because my ego would get in the way and
all kinds of things.
I wasn't ready yet.
And so the university was like,
no,
not ready,
fail,
fail.
And I was like,
man,
I'm just,
I'm 30 and I've failed at everything.
You know,
I scratched out a little money here and there,
you know,
I was doing all right,
doing better than some of my peers when I would go buy bottles at the club and
party,
like I could buy a more expensive bottle than they could.
And so everybody's like,
yeah,
Aubrey,
you're killing.
I'm like,
I'm not fucking killing it.
I'm like blown it.
And that was,
that was tough.
And then finally it just kind of lined up with the right timing and the right
idea and the right person leading it,
meaning me,
and uh,
it was able to come to fruition.
So let's,
let's start with a snapshot of where we are now and then I'm going to go back to
you and your dad and 16 for a second.
Yeah.
So on it,
what is on it?
How many employees do you have?
What are you proudest of that debt on it has done or is doing?
We have on,
it's,
we call it total human optimization.
So what I realized early on is that you couldn't,
and you mentioned this in the Intro,
like balance,
you really can't specialize in only one thing and really reach the potential of
that thing.
You have to support everything else.
Like you can go super hard in one direction,
but your health is going to fall apart,
your relationship's gonna fall apart.
And ultimately that's going to start being,
weight's going to be anchors.
It's gonna drag against your progress and it's going to be a headwind for you in
anything that you're doing.
And it's the same with the body.
Like you can take great supplements,
but if your nutrition is shitty and your workouts are shitty and your sleep is
shitty and your mentality Shitty,
so what?
It's not going to matter.
So total human optimization is the idea to raise everything at the same time and
really try to incrementally improve and it's not as flashy and sexy is this 30
day transformation expert in this one area,
but it really works and it's through to the bone.
And I think that's what I'm probably most proud of is that on it is what it
appears to be like.
You go there,
the people who were there from me to Kyle to everybody's who's in the
organization,
they feel that movement.
The people who follow on it,
I think it's just the vibe and the authenticity of what we stand for.
The ability to be a little bit better tomorrow than you are today.
And I think that's probably what I'm most proud of.
How many employees do you have?
180 employees.
If you count or Yoga Studios and count the gym and count the other entities that
we own.
How many employees did you
10 years ago?
When did on it?
When did,
when was that started in 2011.
Well originally 2010 zero employees.
2010.
I was making like hangover supplements most success party too much.
And I was,
you know,
really a lot of this was,
well where's,
where's the need for me?
Well at that point I was just drinking my head off because I was unhappy.
So I first started making hangover supplements and then realize like,
ah,
that's not where I'm going.
Where I'm going is to really improve my life in all areas.
And that's when we pivoted Alpha brain and different things and yeah,
we started,
we started in,
there was one employee who is my kind of like my right hand guy,
part assistant part,
you know,
whatever,
everything,
the everything got odd job.
100% and then,
uh,
yeah,
we started getting geared up with Alpha brain and then when it hit and we
actually started having sales,
then it was just like grabbing every friend that had something of a shaky job
that I could trust and say,
quit,
come,
you know,
and it's fucking figure it out.
And I was in the attic of a little boutique that my fiance at the time Kaitlin
was running and we were in the attic of this boutique and we were just bringing
out literal trash bags of orders that we were hand labeling,
you know,
from the top of it.
And that's,
that's how it started.
I mean,
we didn't have a lot of fun.
I'd blown through the only funding I got.
I got 100,000 from,
uh,
my friend Bodie Miller,
who's the Olympic skier at the time,
who a really significant friendship for me.
And then an old investment banking contact that somehow didn't go broke when all
the wildcat wells,
you know,
dried up.
And you know,
I don't know how he ever made money because everything I ever saw him do didn't
work.
But he gave me 50 grand,
so I had $110,000 I blew through a lot of that,
trying to market these hangover supplements and it was like literally like the
last $20,000 invested in an order of Alpha brain on net 30 and then it hit,
we sold out in 24 hours and then net 30 meaning you had 30 days to pay for your
main yeah.
And exactly cost.
Exactly.
It was all in man.
It was just like,
here we go.
Let's see.
So I,
I promised to get back to this,
so I want to not leave people hanging and then we're going to come back to the
attic 16 you,
you mentioned you had a lot of,
maybe a complicated relationship with your dad.
Yeah.
Conflicted relationship
visionquest yeah.
Was that an overnight experience or was it multiple overnight.
Overnight.
All right,
so you have this vision quest,
uh,
two things if you're comfortable talking about it.
Yeah.
How was your relationship with your dad?
Complicated.
I think that's true for a lot of people.
That as a,
for those people who want a good quote I think is Ron Doss,
formerly Richard Alpert.
You can look up his history,
but he said,
if you think you're enlightened,
go spend a week with your family.
So we all have our staff,
we all have our stuff.
How was the relationship complicated?
How would you describe it?
And then did the vision quest affect it in any way?
Did,
but that took a long time to unpack.
In fact,
that's still unpacking honestly,
like there's actually been an understanding,
a realization that's actually led to a greater happiness for me.
And,
and I'll talk about that,
you know,
when I get to it.
But if I go from the start,
you know,
my dad was a tortured soul and from his father who I never met,
his father used to hold trials for him and his brother,
he was a lawyer and he would hold trials like Franz Kafka Scowl.
They're like six and eight years old and put him on trial and they'd have to
petition their defense and he would hammer them and cross examine them and then
then read out their sentence,
you know,
and like some crazy shit like that.
So it wasn't ever like physical or sexual,
but like massive like emotional mind fuck series.
Yes.
And so he,
my dad had,
you know,
he had a lot of his own demons and he started on the path to heal himself.
As I said,
to try and pass as little as that is he could off on is,
uh,
off on his sons.
But you know,
he didn't quite get there by the time he had me.
So one little thing I would say,
I remember one time he was playing ping pong.
I was about four years old.
He's playing ping pong,
he missed hits a ball ball,
goes flying off the thing and I run,
I run by and I go home,
run.
Okay.
And I'm like,
the fucking ball went out of the thing two days later,
corners me,
throws me down in a corner and starts yelling at him.
How could you,
how could you insult me like that in front of my competition?
How dare you,
blah,
blah.
And I was like,
wow,
wow.
Like I didn't know.
I couldn't even fathom that.
Like,
you know,
it,
it's so lost,
you know,
gone out of my mind.
Right,
right.
So it built this kind of fear around everything I say could be misinterpreted
and that any issue with that delay,
exactly.
The delay was the killer.
Like if it was right away,
you're like,
you know,
hot stove,
ouch.
Okay,
I get it.
But that forced me to internalize it because I'd be going over everything I said
the previous day,
the previous day.
So there's this massive lack of trust around my dad,
which I didn't really realize.
And then fast going fast forward and we had a good relationship and a lot of
other ways,
you know,
he was a brilliant man and taught me a lot and I'm grateful for our
relationship,
but I didn't realize that I never really trusted men,
particularly men that had that kind of paternal role.
So anybody who I had in that kind of father category,
even peer category,
like even when I give him a hug and be like,
Yo fucking trust,
you know like I don't know if one thing I said you know a while ago or is going
to cause you to go off.
And I didn't really realize that I was doing that to more people other than my
father.
Like it was extending universally to all men until recently,
you know,
someone who I had held in that kind of father mentor kind of role.
Our relationship really got,
you know when a skew and went haywire and I realize like Oh shit,
you know,
I'm really damaged by this.
Like this is really traumatic to me and where's this coming from?
Oh this is coming from my dad.
This is that same pattern repeats just to occur you while you're in the shower
or what [inaudible] we journaling.
What prompted that realization?
Yeah,
I think it was,
it came kind of slowly and it was unpacking,
you know what,
I'm constantly doing different work and introspection and it was somehow that
pain,
that external pain.
Again,
going back to external pain,
being one of those indicators,
like why am I fucking devastated by this?
Like why am I completely floored?
Why am I,
this is applying universally to everything.
I was like really crushed.
Then I couldn't bounce back.
And then so it just forced me to keep looking like,
what is this?
Like why do I care so much and say crush?
Was that something your mentor or the person in that role had said to you that
threw you off?
It was an instance that repeated the pattern where I had,
you know,
and I don't want to get into the details specifically,
but like I had said and done,
you know,
I had said and done some things that were interpreted in a way that I didn't
intend.
And it caused a,
uh,
caused a break in our friendship and,
and a lot of anger.
And so it was that pattern of I'm never safe no matter what I say or do,
it can be interpreted in a different way and I'll never be safe.
And it,
and it really allowed me to look at that and analyze that and say,
all right,
I got to get to the bottom of this and I got to understand where this is coming
from.
And simultaneously,
like I met Kyle Kingsbury who's become one of my best friends probably if I was
to get married now,
he'd be my best man.
And he's also probably the most stable dude I know.
Yeah.
And so like it was a combination of having one example of like the most,
oh,
I can really think I can trust this guy.
Like you can push him to the extreme and he doesn't shift like under pain,
under duress,
under fatigue,
under psychedelics,
under alcohol,
under anything.
Incredible amount of self awareness from what I've observed of him under duress.
I've seen a bunch of grass and he can go from that initial experience of
overwhelm to completely centered and a few minutes.
It's,
it's remarkable.
and we're talking about Kyle Kingsbury,
who is our director of human optimization,
former UFC fighter.
Um,
but yeah,
it was a combination of one spinning off and then one being solid and realizing
somewhere in there,
I can't pinpoint the moment,
but I realized,
oh,
like this is all stuff from my father.
I've never really trusted men ever since that point.
So that was like a second weird coming of age at 36 I'm about to turn 37 where I
finally felt like I wasn't,
I didn't need to prove anything to my dad.
I didn't need to be get validated.
I didn't need to show him that I was worthy of love or any more or any other men
for that matter.
And I could actually trust that I really do have male friends and I really do
have people who I can trust and if they go off,
that's okay.
It's not me,
it's not my fault.
It's just a pattern that happened from when I was growing up and that's been
huge for me.
That's been huge because I've always retreated to females is my solace and my
comfort and having like male friends that I can really rely on and trust and
kind of be vulnerable with in,
in really authentic way.
I mean I would go do ceremonies and stuff,
but I'd always kind of keep my shell up,
you know?
And now to be able to relax into that,
it's just,
I feel like,
uh,
a much happier individual know,
like much more solid like having,
having,
you know,
brothers of the way.
Yeah,
no,
that's cool.
Well,
if half the people you encounter are like potential threats,
that's a lot of day to day existence.
I can't even,
I mean I simply the so much with people who've had both,
they're both those roles be off center,
off Kilter,
you know,
like if you had your mother and your father,
let's say your father was abusive and your mother permitted it and there was
some weird dynamic there and then both sides you don't trust and then you just
don't trust the fucking world.
You know,
I was super lucky.
I had one sock,
one half dialed,
then you know,
so I had a place to retreat,
I had a place to rest.
You know,
if you have neither,
that's a hell of a challenging road.
But the good news is you make it through that and you'll be even stronger
because of it.
Know,
and you can help people if you do the work.
And I'm going to get back to the attic in a second,
but if you do the work,
what do you know?
What I've realized also just recently,
and I mean I'm 40 now,
but if no matter your circumstances or the hand you've been dealt,
if you do the work to uncover the wounds,
heal the wounds,
or at least be accept that they exist and begin to process that,
that you're not only doing the work for yourself,
but you can then in turn help other people who've experienced the same thing or
similar things,
right?
So it's,
it's really valuable work.
Hard to understate.
That's almost the turning point,
right?
When you take your lessons and your knowledge and then you can help other
people.
And at that point you got the inspiration and you got the momentum.
That's the final healing catalyst.
It's not healing yourself.
It's the knowing that you've,
everything that you've suffered,
all of that pain you've endured can now help someone else.
It alchemizes it instantly into something that's valuable,
something you can be grateful for.
And when you're grateful for something,
it's no longer trauma.
Like you've healed it.
Like that's the full circle.
Is gratitude for that,
for what it's given you yet,
at least for me to the regard for myself or healing myself,
what is it sounds really odd to say,
but wasn't enough to motivate me to do the work.
I knew it'd be really difficult,
but as soon as I realized,
oh,
well,
even if I have no regard or very little regard for myself,
if I can then develop a tool kit,
learn about ab and C and impart that to other people,
that's enough to motivate me and since have developed more regard for myself,
but it's like,
hey,
you gotta take what works.
And for me it was that realization,
oh,
I can actually hand this baton off to other people.
Look at,
well,
let's work with what,
what motivates.
Yeah.
Look at every great epic novel.
Like what gets the hero inspired.
It's not him,
it's not his own safety.
He's fine like chopping wood and being in the forest.
But when you know,
the oppressing force starts fucking with his family or starts fucking with his
kids,
you know,
then then you unleash William Wallace.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
like if they didn't slip Mearns throat,
like there may not be Scotland's right.
Is,
you know,
there's just,
there's just the UK,
you know what I mean?
Like what we're wired to really care for those we love almost more than
ourselves.
It's just part of the social dynamic.
And you can tap in,
you can like hack into that current and use that to your advantage.
And that's like the cleanest burning fuel you got.
That's like a fusion reactor from the sun,
you know?
And that's,
that's really what's going to motivate you.
Not the other,
you know,
ego based stuff that's like burning coal.
You know,
you're going to run out of that shit at some point and it's not going to work
for you.
And you have to breathe in the fumes.
Exactly.
So you'd,
you'd just turning or you have turned 37 tomorrow.
Tomorrow.
Thanks man.
Uh,
all right.
37.
So if we rewind the clock,
I think you said 2011,
right?
So you're like 29 30
and fulfilling orders out of the attic.
I remember those days,
by the way,
when I started my first real business also in sports nutrition,
I remember the,
when I decided to get a fulfillment company was when I was,
I had to race off to the post office to ship off packages.
My car wouldn't start.
So I got on my motorcycle used motorcycle with a garbage bag,
big dark garbage bag full of boxes.
And I'm wrapping it around the throttle to try to make it to the post office.
Almost die obviously.
And uh,
I get back,
I'm like,
that was dumb.
You didn't want to go Santa Claus.
I hold it over.
I'd have to,
I'd have to really switch grips if I went Santa Claus.
So I decided just to risk life and limb with it on the throttle and it came
back.
I was like,
okay,
now it's time to start to outsource things up.
The question I wanted to ask you is,
all right,
so you,
you get up to betting the farm on,
which was a very small farm in the backyard on this manufacturing on Alpha brain
with net 30 terms.
Uh,
let's,
if we bounce out,
say two years,
so to 32
from 16 to 32 could even be earlier for like 12 to 32.
Do you remember,
uh,
any point in time when you were like,
wow,
this is the richest I've ever felt.
Cause I remember,
I remember one very specific day in my experience,
but when
was that?
What was that moment when you're like,
wow,
well I feel successful or I,
this is more than I could have anticipated.
Yeah.
I mean that happened pretty quick after that because that,
you know,
with those net 30 terms,
I was able to,
in the sales I was really able to scale pretty aggressively without taking on
extra capital or anything.
And we had no overhead.
I mean that was just the cost of the product itself and a couple friends who
were paying like 25 30 grand,
whatever,
we could kind of pushed together.
And then,
you know,
it started to grow a little bit from there.
But it was a lot of sales,
you know,
just product costs,
a lot of shipments,
no additional advertising.
Cause at that point,
you know,
Rogan was the business partner,
he was the advertising engine he'd bought into the company.
So I'd give an equity in exchange for the,
for the marketing.
And I was,
you know,
there was serious money coming in and I started looking at houses and I was
looking at this house and I was thinking maybe,
you know,
600 $700,000 range,
really get a house I can sink my teeth into.
And I saw this house that was $1 million and I was like $1 million house.
Damn.
I was like,
I think I can swing it.
I think I can fucking swing it,
you know?
And it was just,
cause it was my,
it was my dream house,
you know,
it had a nice backyard and I envisioned what's there now,
which is ax throwing and slack line and,
and pool and deck and fire pit.
I was like,
I can do this here in this house.
And it had my style and I just,
you know,
at that point again a little bit early,
but I still went for it.
Like I think I can,
this thing looks solid enough,
I can go in.
And when I went into that house,
that was like a big moment for me because that was a,
that was a real house.
That was like a,
it was a big boy house.
I was like,
I got to fucking big boy.
And that was a,
that was really the moment for me.
I was like,
damn,
this is awesome here.
And you've turned it into the Aubrey Marcus House of Ninja Warrior training,
sort of delight.
It's been heaven.
You mentioned a name that for those people who don't have contacts,
I want to explore for a second.
So you mentioned Rogan,
Joe Rogan.
So some of you listening of course know who Joe is.
Uh,
most certainly,
uh,
I would say arguably the most powerful single to the interview format.
Podcaster.
Yeah.
Period.
Um,
part of the inspiration,
certainly one of the inspirations for me starting my own podcast was being
across the table from Joe and having such a wonderful experience.
Yeah.
Able to go long form be myself,
although robes,
he fed me,
you know,
I don't know if I ever told you this just I'm going to digress for a second
cause that's what I do very first time I was on his show,
he said,
because I've been on twice.
He said,
um,
do you want some bulletproof coffee?
Sure.
So give me like a huge,
I mean it must've been like 24 ounces of bulletproof coffee and then he goes,
you want some Alpha brain?
I was like,
sure.
So I had like a handful of Alpha brain and then he goes,
do you want some pot?
And I was like,
I don't even smoke pot,
but I'm a little intimidated Joseph intense guy and maybe it's spending time in
Japan.
I was like,
can't say no.
All right.
So I go into this interview on like 24 ounces of butter coffee,
a handful of Alpha brain end pot,
which I never can.
I very rarely consumed nothing against it.
It's just not really my plant and man,
Oh man,
that was,
that was a hell of an experience.
Uh,
but uh,
how did you first meet jokes?
I think this is going to tie into maybe a theme that I want to explore.
I listened to Joe do comedy,
you know,
and I'd seen him as,
I was a huge UFC fan all the way from UFC one.
Literally cause my dad was a fan of the sport.
We'd watch that together.
That was some of the good times memories is watching.
It's brutal first we se.
Yeah,
right.
Hot Foot slider that tooth out at as sumo mellow guy and to the commentators.
Oh boy is different.
Yeah.
That was pretty epic and a,
so I'd seen him there.
And so I think that probably drew me to listen to his comedy show.
And then I listened to his comedy show.
I was like,
Oh shit.
He's thinking about the same things that I'm thinking about.
Like he's done psychedelics ease in to Maureen about aliens and super volcanoes
and all this stuff.
It's like man,
I gotta meet this guy and I kept,
I kept running into them at different events cause I go to some of the UFC,
you know,
when I could and I'd see him out in the,
at that point he was still going to clubs and occasionally going to strip clubs
and we had the podcast at this point.
Uh,
no I don't think he did and when I first started at that point and then,
um,
but you know,
I'm just a fan at that point so and say,
hey Joe,
you know,
and Blah Blah Blah and you know,
you get your in like kind of fan zone fans at that point.
And you know,
I kept,
I saw more of his comedy show.
Then you launched the podcast and then at that was super early in the podcast
game and he had a no commercials and it's just him and red band and they were
just bullshit.
And it was just like a fun thing that everybody who knows Joe Rogan,
like all in caps,
marquee Joe Rogan.
She'd go back and see some of the early shows.
No,
no.
Yeah,
I think it's inspiring to see where we're up again.
No doubt.
And I had an idea at that point you're like,
oh well he doesn't have advertising on his show.
Maybe I'll hit him up for,
you know,
to do some advertising and use that as a chance to like meet him and maybe
elevate out of the fan zone so we can have a conversation.
So I remember I set up a lunch meeting to just 30 minutes to just meet
somewhere,
talk to them about advertising on a show.
This was in la?
Yeah.
And a fly out just for this or you already that did.
And actually it was,
it was interesting.
It was like the universe gave me a test.
So Bodie Miller,
who I mentioned,
four Olympic skier,
you know,
still in his playboy mode at the time.
He invited me for my first Kentucky Derby experience and it was like,
Oh man,
I got a cancellation.
Got Full VIP access,
craziest parties you've ever seen suite at the Kentucky Derby.
And I was like,
and I had that one meeting with Rogan that was right in the middle of that.
I was like,
man,
I can't go.
I gotta take this meeting with Joe.
And it was like a cool test.
We'll test,
you know.
And um,
so I took that meeting and a 30 minute meeting to talk about advertising quickly
turned into all those things so I can tell like super volcanoes and genetic
bottleneck theory and aliens and all the philosophical things that we talked
about.
And after that he's like,
hey man,
you know,
I'd love to have you come on the show and we can talk more about this.
So went on the show and just as friends just started having a relationship with
them.
And it was a couple of years after that,
I asked him the question like,
hey man,
like what supplement would you like the best yourself?
And he's like,
Oh yeah,
I'm into new nootropics.
And I was like,
man,
I'm going to make the best one that's ever been made and I'll let you know about
it.
All right.
So this was like made to order.
It's just like,
yeah,
this is it.
Bespoke Joseph.
Yeah.
Bespoke.
It's,
I didn't know that.
Now you mentioned in passing something earlier,
and I don't know if this is the product that you were meeting to advertise.
Oh,
I bet it was.
So you mentioned the SDX toy.
Oh yeah.
Well this was,
we talking to,
this was the number one male cell number one selling male sex toy in the world.
The one and only fleshlight fleshlight or a convenient pocket pussy concealed in
a obnoxiously large flashlight container,
which by the way,
I should say,
uh,
on this podcast,
had Alice Little,
who is the number one earning as far as I know,
legal sex worker in the u s and one of her top recommendations was,
I wish I could or her pronouncements was,
I wish I could get a fleshlight for every male in the country for a number of
different reasons.
So
you've left a legacy.
All right?
So the people can look that up if they would like,
but that was,
that was the co,
the product context for that meeting.
That was,
that was the,
that was the client that I was working with and I was like,
Oh man,
maybe John will do something with this.
And Joe brought that to his people.
If people are like,
no way,
you can't do that when you say clients.
So you've,
you've done a lot of different things at this point on it does not exist on,
it does not exist.
So I have a marketing company and that Boutique Marketing Company has,
you know,
a few people that are working with me and I have,
again,
a bunch of clients,
most of which failed.
But I couldn't fail at selling sex toys because people just want things to fuck.
It was very easy,
easy thing to learn and not suck at.
So I was able to help make that thing work.
And uh,
yeah,
so I had that one going and you know,
he,
he liked just the ridiculousness of it and he liked the idea of not taking this
show too seriously to do something like that.
And so he just went for it.
And so if you go back to the old diaries,
there'll be old flashlight.
And I remember,
might actually there.
Well,
let's see.
So I came about now,
did the,
did the fleshlight and on it
overlap at all or no,
it did not.
So yeah,
I started on it after I actually got myself in a position where,
um,
I was able to transition out of that company with some severance.
Never got any other in incentives,
but got a pretty generous severance.
And took that and just rode it into,
you know,
starting on it and just running.
And then I had $110,000 and I'd tried to dip into that as little as possible
with my own,
you know,
utilization.
That was the severance.
No,
that was the investment from Cody.
Got It.
Run the other person and plus the severance and just kind of rode that to the,
to the very brink of nothing.
And then again,
it just came through like right in the nick of time.
What,
what are some of the,
if,
if I know you read a lot of senior library?
Uh,
it's one of the first things I do.
If I get someone's house and I see a bookshelf or bookshelves as I go start
browsing because you can learn a lot by browsing,
uh,
including which books?
I haven't read it.
Not In your case,
but it's like if you see Warren piece,
you're like,
all right.
Yeah,
definitely Moby Dick.
Like,
ask about those.
I have Warren because I'm like,
well,
I haven't read it.
It's too,
it's too intimidating.
I will get to eventually,
but maybe,
well maybe,
yes.
Dot.
That dot.
Maybe which books or resources do you view as having been very helpful in early
days
of,
of on it or later,
but are there any particular books that helped you or helped you think about and
develop the business?
There is a direct correlation between my inner work and the outer success of on
it.
Like that correlation is as clean a an association as anything I have.
So I haven't been one that's red.
A lot of business books,
a lot of the books that I've read have been oh yeah.
And your game.
And you know,
there's been some really significant books that I've read that have kind of
shaped who I am.
And I think the first was kind of following that line of the Toltec philosophy
from crazy Carlos Castaneda through Don Miguel Ruiz.
And I think actually his most powerful book,
although it's a little bit hard to get into,
is the Toltec art of life and death,
which is a pot.
A lot of people know Don Miguel Ruiz from the four agreements or agreements.
Yeah.
And then he wrote mastery of love,
which is an incredible exploration of love and relationship.
And then his true masterwork is the Toltec art of life and death.
And then the thing I liked about it is it was the first complete system,
a complete spiritual,
physical,
emotional system that you know,
was self contained.
Like it was like its own religion to a certain extent.
But except it was something that I could believe and I can buy into and was
practical and I could utilize those principles of the warrior ethos and the
principles of the Nog.
Well the artist who paints his masterpiece,
you know,
versus the person who allows the mid totay they called it,
which is the dream of the world to shape their experience.
And so that transition from just allowing everything,
expectations and pressures from this person and that person to shape who I was
to being becoming the Nog.
Well the artists who,
who are proactive,
who uses your intention to actually create the world around him and paint that
masterpiece and,
and the laughter as the kind of guide,
you know,
knowing that you've made it.
And I always say that like,
you can tell a spiritual master by the sound of their laughter.
Like if they aren't laughing,
I'm not going to drink your cup.
Iowasca like if you don't have a good belly laugh,
like you're missing the point,
you know?
And,
and that's been a really solid guide book in a place that if anybody's
searching,
you know,
I would definitely check out Toltec philosophy Toltec art of life and death.
Any other books come to mind,
you know,
as far as like building,
cause part of building a company is building like a scale of 10 years ago came
to you and said,
I need three books.
Yeah.
What do you recommend?
Aldous Huxley's island I think was another crucial book for me.
And that was,
um,
that was utopian fiction.
But the beauty of that is it was seeing how a system could work in mass,
you know?
And it was the first exposure to rewriting the rules of how everything could be
and understanding like,
oh,
we could just change everything.
Like everything could be malleable.
And then what are the downstream effects?
And it's that classic,
classic clash of Utopia versus dystopia and how it all merges.
And that's been something I've consistently back on with a lot of like help in
principles.
So I think that one was huge.
Um,
and then honestly,
personally this has nothing to do with on it,
but personally the book sex at dawn by Chris Ryan was probably the third most
influential single book.
Uh,
because at that point I was frustrated in conventional monogamous relationship
and I thought that humans were like lions and we were supposed to fight to the
death to protect all our mates and that women should be happy if they found the
right line,
you know,
and sex at dawn,
it's like,
no,
no.
Humans like having sex both sides.
We're always going to like having sex.
And that's just the nature of things.
And I go,
Oh man,
like I had this wrong.
It's not just me that's supposed to want other lovers.
It's everybody that's,
you know,
from an instinctive primitive concept really is open to having a more expanded
view of sexuality.
And that's led me down.
That was the initial domino that led me down the path of exploring open
relationship,
which has been a huge advancement in my own personal happiness,
fulfillment,
challenging as hell.
I mean challenging as hell,
but that book,
if it wasn't for that book,
I don't think I ever would have given it a try because I was operating under a
false premise.
So for people who are listening and they're like,
you know what,
I'd like to give that more expanded view of sexuality,
shot lock,
any,
any guideposts,
any particular guidelines
you have to be super committed,
like do not,
you know,
like know that it's going to be hell.
Like you can have it all sorted.
Man.
I had it all sorted,
mentally understood it philosophically understood spiritually.
I understood it biologically understood it in evolutionary terms,
but the moment that Whitney had another lover,
I spent 24 hours crawling around on the ground,
vomiting every time I thought of her having sex with somebody else,
like literally dry heaving,
right?
Like a massive purge that I couldn't even shake myself out of like,
and that was step one.
And then it gets a little bit better from there if you continue to do the work.
But it takes a while to make it through.
Like you got to literally go through the darkness,
the dark night of the soul,
of your own insecurities,
all your fears and insecurities and validation points.
Everything is going to be stress tested and challenged.
If you make it through,
you'll be really free.
These things like jealousy,
these things that can securities,
they will get pushed to the point where you either fix them or you just suffer
and,
and in unbearable pain.
So it forces you,
again,
external pain is that force.
It'll put you in pain and then it's up to you whether you can fix it.
So we could spend an entire podcast just discussed.
Totally.
You and I have spent the equivalent of many podcasts talking about this.
Yeah.
So maybe another time,
but if we're looking back,
this could be professional or personal and of course they're,
so,
I mean the two sides of the same coin.
Yeah.
No matter how you slice it.
But do you have any particular failure that you can discuss?
Um,
and I put failure in quotation because the,
the goal is to describe a failure that leader ended up setting the stage or
planting a seed for a success later down the line.
Are there any failures that come to mind or a failure that you just learned a
lot from and therefore that helped you?
You know,
I failed.
It's so many things and every single failure was helpful.
Like every single fucking failure was helpful.
And there's not one that stands out,
but there's some that I remember,
like I remember early in the days of on and I was allowing myself to get really
stressed and I was trying to record a video and someone was knocking on my door
and I didn't respond.
I was trying to stay in line with video and they kept knocking and they kept
knocking.
This was when we had about 12 employees,
14 employees,
and I blew up.
I lost it.
You know,
a little bit of my dad coming out.
Why,
what the fuck do you want?
If I don't answer the door when you knock,
then I'm fucking busy.
Right.
You know,
I blew up.
Right?
And then I was like,
oh man.
And I go out and I opened the door and it was like the sweetest employee we had,
you know,
and I think her name was Samantha and she's crying and I go,
oh my God,
like what did I just do?
Like she didn't know.
And that was like a hard lesson.
Like I am not going to lose my temper at no matter what is going on with my
life,
I will not allow my anger to come out on my employees ever.
You know?
And it was like this deep,
like I interned it like that was deeply painful for me.
Times I've done that in relationships too.
You know,
where I've projected my own shit and put that on somebody else and watch them
suffer from the pain that I've caused.
And then having to deal with that businesses,
every business,
like I said,
every business I did failed.
And then me questioning my own self worth.
Like I'm grateful for all of that.
And I'm sorry for the people who had to suffer along the way that people who bet
on me and invested in me.
And I failed in their shit and the people who I hurt with my anger and the
people who I hurt with my projections.
But I'm grateful for the experience because without all of that,
and without the grace of that happening,
I wouldn't be a fraction who I am
allergic to anger
thing.
I grapple with myself.
Uh,
the anger piece.
I'd love to touch on this because this is also part of my familiar cast
characters and I think I've greatly improved over time with managing that as a,
as an impulse,
something that,
that really was embedded in me early.
And,
uh,
after that experience,
what was your pattern interrupt?
What did you say to yourself when you felt like the physiological response of
about to hit takeoff in terms of losing temporary,
getting angry,
what had,
what was the,
was the technique,
what was the approach?
You know,
it coincided with me talking because I started talking about that experience and
then I was like,
yeah,
of course.
I was talking to my friend Duncan Trussell,
who's pretty steeped in kind of Buddhist philosophy and he had a name for it and
I think it was [inaudible] and it's that feeling you get,
it's that welling of energy,
it's,
and it actually feels good and I think it was acknowledging like there's some
part of you that when that anger is coming it like feels good.
It's a sense of power that's rising and that it's identifying that and the,
and the Toltec philosophy offs also helps us.
Don Miguel help me with that.
But you feel it rising and it's like the sweat,
it's like the swell of a wave and there's a choice right there where you either
paddle or you don't paddle.
But to really identify the swell and identify like,
Oh yeah,
this is going to feel good.
Like that power putting on that mantle and like breathing fire.
Like it's going to feel good in certain ways,
but the ramifications like never feel good.
You know,
the burning bodies,
the house is on fire when you're breathing that dragon fire,
that never feels good.
So it's really a hard choice.
I call it mental override to interrupt that,
that pattern,
when I feel that shrimp or whatever the,
whatever Dunkin called it,
that moment of takeoff where I start to bristle and the dragon fucking tentacles
come out and it starts to come.
Like I can identify.
Actually,
oddly enough,
I haven't felt this in a long time.
I felt that yesterday,
like yesterday and I looked,
I was leaving my office and literally I haven't been this angry in a long time
and someone,
you know,
someone on my team screwed something up super bad and it was the second time on
the same thing.
I was like,
oh my God.
And I found out about at seven o'clock and I looked at a table and I wanted to
smash it.
I wanted to take the table and throw it on the ground and like smash it.
And then I was like,
oh yeah,
there's that thing.
Like I remember how I did deal with this thing.
All right,
I'm going to go for a walk outside and I would go for a walk outside.
And then I read this Japanese study and I'd talk about this in my book where six
breaths,
six deep breaths actually lowers blood pressure.
So they say,
take a breath.
It's not a breath,
it's six like six is the amount that it requires to get that physiological
response.
So I took my six breasts,
I walked outside and it wasn't gone.
Like I carried it for a while.
I talked to people,
but at least eliminated it enough that that initial wave of the,
the big wave of the swell past.
So the big wave of the swell past,
and I paddled into a few other little ones.
You know,
I body surfed on some Whitewater of that rage for a little while,
a little long boy.
Oh yeah.
And I,
you know,
I'm fucking hammered a few emails and you don't paddle into it a little bit,
but just my ability to recognize that and then trust the process that I'll be
grateful that I didn't paddle into that wave,
even if it would have felt good at the moment.
Um,
it's just been a,
a gradual,
slow experience.
Well,
you mentioned a couple of things I want to underscore.
Number one is that
it's not a binary pass fail.
Right.
It's not,
it's not,
I completely quelled all of my anger before I succeeded and if I didn't do that,
it's a failure.
It's like,
no,
if you dial it back 10%
that's yeah.
Big Deal.
Totally.
Right.
It's the,
it's the difference between like,
Hey,
fuck face in an email and like,
dear John,
right.
That's 10% is really meaningful.
Yeah.
Uh,
so that's,
that's one thing that it can be incremental,
but the downstream effect of it can be much larger than that small incremental
change.
And you feel the second when you're talking about failures is that what a lot of
per person might perceive as a failure,
which is a path that isn't taken to completion over 10 20,
30 years can still have a lot of value.
And that's why I brought up the fleshlight.
Right.
Like if it were not for that,
you wouldn't have had the context to have the meeting.
Yup.
Which then led to I owe my success to pocket pussy.
Well that,
that that actually leads us to,
this might be your answer.
Uh,
this,
this leads us to,
I'm going to hit a couple of,
uh,
couple of rapid fire questions.
I'll try not to make them long winded and therefore not wrapping it all.
Yeah.
But if you could put one short message,
word,
quote,
anything on a billboard,
metaphorically speaking,
just to get a message out to millions or billions of people,
what would you put on it?
You know,
I heard you ask this question to Wim Hoff and he said,
breathe motherfucker either motherfucker.
That was like the best answer to that.
So I think about this and you know,
I think other podcasters who've Kinda co-opted that question and ask it and you
know,
I was thinking about that question and you know,
I was thinking I wasn't happy with my answer and then I realized like what I
feel now,
what best express the state I'm in is what I would put on that billboard that
was shown everywhere.
I would say welcome to heaven population,
everyone.
And that's really what I feel like we have this choice right now to engage with
life,
all of life and all the opportunity.
Just smell and eat and travel and converse and meet people and have sex and
enjoy and create and build like this can be having.
But we got to get out of our own mental health first.
And so reminding people like,
Hey,
you know,
all right,
extenuating circumstances maybe you know Sarajevo in certain places.
Yeah,
it's fucking tough.
I get it externally it might be hell,
but for most of us,
especially listening to this podcast,
we're in heaven,
we're in heaven like,
and it's just our choice whether we want to engage in it that way or whether we
want to get stuck in our own patterns that keep us in hell.
What,
what tools?
And I'll volunteer one.
I'm,
I'm a Beta testing this so it's not really fair,
but I'm Beta testing the waking up APP,
which Sam Harris is putting together and it's,
it's actually been tremendously helpful and very unlike other programs that
tested for producing the non ordinary states of awareness that one might
correlate to the second Adeleke experience and Sam's no stranger in that arena,
but he certainly,
uh,
passed on the chemical and plant to focus
on the meditative component.
Uh,
and I've found that very helpful for becoming less reactive and more response
able in terms of being able to choose the lens through which I look at the day
and my interactions.
What,
what else have you found helpful personally for living that billboard?
You know,
one of the best ones that I've found is came to me really unusually and it's the
practice of ecstatic dance and cause a lot of,
even psychedelics,
psychedelics,
that kind of project your consciousness out of body,
you know,
from my very first experience was like my body was gone.
Like I didn't have that body somatic awareness.
So it was creating and patterning the separation between consciousness,
mind,
and body.
And then when I first did the ecstatic dance practice,
I had no idea.
I was like,
oh my gosh,
this is really uncomfortable.
Because the idea is you listen to music and then you just move.
Not trying to have a blindfold a lot of times are really dark room and you just
move and expressive ways that push the boundaries of what your body is
comfortable with,
not physically,
but comfortable and moving and just collapsed the mind.
Get to a state of superfluidity kind of flow state where it's just music and
body.
And I was shocked at how I responded.
I mean,
tons of emotions came up,
tons of like clarity came up.
I had visions that were coming through in that experience and it was just
massive,
massive transformation for me because I felt it all the way through to my cells,
you know,
instead of getting the body out of the way,
it was using the body as a tool to enhance my consciousness.
And so it unified everything else instead of siloing it and kind of pulling it
apart.
Right?
It was pushing it all together in a really powerful way.
And you know,
I've started leading those practices and doing those frequently.
Like I will,
if I'm feeling Funky,
I'll just put on music,
put on a Hoodie and I can be anywhere.
I was just in Venice doing it and my little rental house in the middle of the
day and I felt a feeling kind of funky from,
I'm recording the book and whatever.
I just start moving and I contentionally find those patterns that sends off the
alarm signals.
Like don't move your hips like that cause you'll be gay if you like.
If you move your arms too far out,
like they extend beyond one foot Dotoly gay,
you can't do that,
you know,
and just force yourself to move into these other patterns that you're
uncomfortable with and let it let your body like let your body loose,
like let your body free.
We bind that up just like we bind up our psyche and when you unbind the body and
allow it to express freely in this safe container,
not saying go to the club and do it.
You know?
That's a lot of external pressure,
right?
But in this case,
you know,
do it by yourself in a dark room.
Put on some music,
put on something with a tribal beat and force yourself to move in those
uncomfortable patterns and see what boundaries and restrictions you have for
yourself.
And then realize like where is that coming from?
Yeah.
I can't allow myself to move in space right by myself in the dark.
What the hell?
You know?
And so that's been a really cool tool for me that I don't think a lot of people
are engaging,
but it's something that ancestrally,
man,
everybody was dancing as part of like Sundance rituals,
trance dance rituals,
all these dance rituals.
That was part of a major part of ceremony for people.
And I think it's great to make you feel more human again and take that
performance aspect off of dancing.
Like when you dance in public,
it's like a mating dance.
It's like performance show.
It's all about how you look in this case and not,
it doesn't matter how you look.
It doesn't matter if these been approximates dancing as well.
Getting your body to move.
And so many times just the tears will flow and the emotions will come up.
Sometimes rage and anger sometimes.
Ah,
well I'll come out in that too if I've been bottling that up.
So it just allows the instrument to release and expel anything that's been
holding.
And typically by the end,
you know,
you just allow that,
those snowflakes,
the joy to just come in and touch the skin.
It's,
it's dope.
How long,
how long is the session typically?
How frequently do you try and do it?
Any music recommendations?
Yeah.
Um,
you can do it shorter,
but I think minimum you need,
you need probably 2030 minutes because the first 10,
15 minutes you're still going to be getting into it.
And like the real magic happens in the middle.
And then fatigue starts setting depending on your fitness level,
around 30 to 40 minutes.
So I try to take an arch from,
actually when I do it,
I follow Stan graphs,
basic prenatal matrix kind of model.
I don't know what that is.
Okay.
So that starts like you're in the womb,
right?
It's something very comfortable.
Some kind of music that's,
you know,
smooth.
It's like you're,
everything's taken care of.
The universe is good.
Some very kind of happy.
Any,
any playlist.
So you can recommend or um,
what would people search for that,
for that music?
Anything with kind of like a very slow,
positive kind of be,
you know,
I have,
I have like obscure spiritual music,
massage,
tribal music.
Yeah.
It's just like,
feels good,
it's happy.
And then,
um,
then I go into,
then the next thing that happens is like the water breaks is chaos,
right?
So chaos around you.
You know,
you're imagining in this,
in the birth process,
the water breaks,
you don't know what's happening in the world as it allows is like five minutes,
10 minutes,
I'd like six,
seven minutes and it's just kind of sweating.
I usually stretch.
A lot of times it's kind of stretch.
Sometimes I lie on the ground a little bit,
a little bit,
joint mobility,
a little bit stretched and getting into it.
And then,
you know,
if I'm doing the practice,
I'll go into that more chaotic mode,
which is a little still hard to dance to.
And it forces me to do weird patterns.
And I like violin,
like Lindsey Sterling.
Oh yeah,
that's a great one.
And then so it's like some weird kind of Staccato violence and beats antique.
Uh,
music is sometimes good in there.
Something that you tend to is great.
Beats Antique,
exhaustive Lindsey Stirling Violin.
Also,
we brought up Alice Little earlier,
one of her favorite types of music to have sex to no shit side.
And I see that,
I see that.
Then from there I go to like there is the fight and that's where you actually
see the birth canal and you know,
you have a goal,
tunnel vision.
You got to get out,
you got to breathe,
you're going to fight with everything you have to breathe.
And that's that warrior archetype.
So for that it's almost always tribe called red.
Like that's my go to.
And that's like Edm mixed with um,
like tribal native American cries and there's some great,
great tracks or that,
um,
like,
uh,
electric powwow,
like some awesome tracks for that.
And then so from there,
and that's where you really start to express that kind of warrior archetype.
And allow any of those emotions to come.
And then finally at the end is the more kind of ecstatic,
blissful,
but still a beat.
So something like really upbeat Edm or some really positive,
uplifting music.
And I usually will take a break with something that's kind of quiet and serene,
like welcome to Africa.
Everything is beautiful kind of vibe.
And then into some more,
you know,
positive message like Edm and just kind of dance it out and really enjoy and
express like the happiness of taking that breath.
Rebirthing becoming a new,
you know,
being,
embracing your new self.
And that's the BBM four,
which is the,
you know,
the ecstasy of,
of breath and a,
and so that's the,
that's the pathway for the full kind of shamonic roads.
Sometimes I'll just go straight to the,
uh,
straight to the tribe called red.
My,
you know,
are,
I think you've met him to Port Augie who came out with this Iowasca remixed
album.
He's got a couple of great tribal drum tracks,
which are good.
Um,
there's a remix from drum spider and a mosaic in there.
I think it's tracks three and tracks eight on that.
You can get it on Spotify.
Um,
but I can share a Spotify playlist to have her for an ecstatic dance.
I will,
for everybody listening,
I'll put the Spotify playlist in the show notes and it's what strikes me
listening to this,
because I,
I knew nothing about extended dance is that the narrative is really important.
A meeting,
it seems like the,
it's not,
it's not the hero's journey,
but the,
the narrative arc of the playlist is really important.
Yeah.
And this is just something that I came up with.
I've been,
uh,
obviously,
you know,
my father worked with Stan Grof,
so I've been,
he's used that metaphor and it can just kind of stuck with me like,
oh yeah,
these are all things we feel.
Everything's cool.
Oh Shit,
everything's not cool.
Everything's fucked up.
And then like,
all right,
everything's fucked up and I'm going to fight and I don't care and there's a way
out and I'm going to fucking make it.
And it's just kind of pound your chest.
Like,
I got this.
And then it's like through the other side.
Like I got this because I got all this help and I'm fucking grateful and here I
am.
And that's,
you know,
the tears really flow like at the end.
And you're like,
man,
life is good.
And do you use this therapeutically when needed or was it something that you do?
Uh,
preemptively or on a scheduled basis to prevent?
Yeah,
I should do it more like prophylactically,
like preventatively,
but I,
I tend to do it when I feel funky.
Like when I feel Funky,
I'm either changing my temperature drastically going in the sauna,
um,
or join in the cold or doing something like this and,
but this is probably the best tool because everything,
it really just unifies everything for me.
You know,
it brings,
brings it all together.
You don't need anything,
you just need a little bit of privacy or someone you feel comfortable.
Now at this point I'm actually comfortable doing it with other people like
watching,
cause I've talked about it and um,
you know,
and it's a little external pressure,
but then you just breathe into that pressure.
Like the,
the goal here is to go where you're uncomfortable.
So like when you're comfortable alone,
then invite somebody who might be a little judgmental and see,
all right,
can you still dance?
Can you still do it?
Because I guarantee you by the time you're done and you've just expressed
yourself,
their judgment's going to be gone and they'll probably be dancing with you,
you know,
so breathing in and it's that,
kind of stoic training,
like breathe into those areas where you feel restricted,
where you feel judgmental,
where you feel like the eyes are on you and try to unify that all together.
Yeah.
It reminds me of a quote and I'm not going to get the attribution right.
Wait a second.
Donald Neale Walsch,
maybe someone,
I'm sure it might be Jim around,
someone can correct me,
but life begins at the end of your comfort zone.
This is,
and how do you put that into practice?
It's with activities like this,
training regiments like this,
especially for men who are tough,
like men are tough and like a tough man and get in a cold bath and a tough man.
You can get in a,
in a sauna for a long time.
And it's like,
it's in our sweet spot.
We're like,
yeah,
I got that.
It's uncomfortable discomfort.
It's comfortable discomfort.
This is uncomfortable.
This guy getting your arms way out there and moving those around and checking
your hips.
Woo.
That's uncomfortable.
Yeah.
Comfortable.
But when you break those patterns,
then there's just a whole new freedom that's available.
So you mentioned,
we'll,
we'll go for just a couple more minutes,
but you mentioned the book.
So I've copied this at home and the number of people picked it up and also
almost immediately gone to the sex chapters under understandably.
But can you describe the book?
Give us,
give us,
uh,
a preview.
Why,
why the book?
What is it called?
Had you choose the contents.
So let's start there.
What really this book is the embodiment of that idea of total human
optimization,
which is not just one thing.
You know,
I really admire the people,
you know,
yourself is one of those people.
You'll track something down to the very end degree and like really bring home
the bones of that truth from your journey.
And I've been surrounded by a lot of people who've done that,
but what I felt like was missing was someone to bring it all together.
Like bring all the practices who've tried all of the different things and how
does that look?
How does it look to go through a day like what's the morning things you do?
Okay.
Hydration,
light,
movement.
Okay.
Then how do you bring in Wim Hoff breathing and cold exposure,
heat exposure.
What are the nutrition principles you want?
Like how do you optimize your commute to work?
What are some workplace practices that you've learned?
Then how when you go home,
how do you relax and connect with yourself and connect with your family and your
friends and how do you drink a glass of wine?
What's too much glass of what's too much wine?
What happens when you drink too much?
Because that's all part of life.
Like addressing all of those things,
how to have great sex and then how to,
you know,
transition from that into the time before bed where you're taking care of
yourself and journaling.
And then from there,
the sleep practices sleep was a huge one for me because everybody is telling
you,
and there's a bunch of bullshit out there.
Like everybody's saying,
Oh,
you need eight,
eight,
eight hours of uninterrupted sleep.
Like that's a fucking fantasy.
Like I might as well be riding a fucking unicorn with the rainbow headband.
Like if that's not going to happen for me,
you know.
So I read Nick Little Hill's books,
sleep,
and he talks about getting 30 to 35 sleep cycles a week.
And then changing the dynamic of that,
utilizing naps more.
I napped right before this podcast and how naps are reliably shown to be more
effective than more overnight sleep or more coffee.
And so just bringing in all these interesting things from books I've read,
people I've met with,
you know,
people who've researched in different areas and try to bring this into a
comprehensive day along with all my own mindset practices.
Like talking about mental override,
telling stories about Bodie Miller and the great fighters I know and the great
champions.
I know.
And just put this together and also remind people like,
Hey,
like I'm not,
I haven't got it all right.
You know,
I tell the stories of when I used to eat like relentlessly eat cinnamon pop
tarts.
I like how unbelievably unfathomably nutritionally bad that was,
you know,
it's like sugar frosting on sugar dough,
on sugar filling like triple the triple crown.
What was that?
You know,
but I was there,
I did that stuff.
The double western Bacon cheeseburgers and how,
what the new double western Bacon cheeseburger looks like with grass fed beef
and raw cheese and sprouted or sourdough bread and,
and how you can just live this robust life,
you know,
not engaging with capital f fear,
which is I think the virus that underpins a lot of our malaise and try to have a
real healthy,
joyful expression and you know,
recognize this life,
as I said on that billboard,
you know,
welcome to have it.
What is the title of the book books called own the day.
Own your life.
And the idea is,
you know,
fuck all these long winded transformational programs.
We focus on one thing for 30 days,
40 days,
90 days.
Let's just focus on doing one day awesomely,
you know,
from top to bottom,
schedule it out,
get all the practices in line.
I have very clear prescriptions.
Let's just focus on one day and see how you feel living one day like that.
And that's all you gotta do.
Just commit to one day,
not only one day,
just commit to one hour at a time.
Just commit to like,
all right,
what are the three things I've got to do when I wake up?
All Right,
12 ounces of water with some sea salt and some lemon.
Okay,
I got that.
All right,
10 minutes of sunlight.
Okay,
I got that.
A little bit of movement.
Okay,
I got that.
Who onto the next thing you know,
that's all he gotta do.
Step by step.
Relax into the process.
Do it for one day and see what changes in your life.
And when in doubt,
six breaths,
six breaths to quell the dragon fire.
So you don't burn down villages.
Uh,
what,
uh,
this is the,
the book.
Do you have a,
do you have a
site for the book?
Yeah,
own the day.
book.com the day book.com.
And if,
if you were,
let's see,
I'm trying to think of the right age to,
to see,
you can choose the age of your younger self.
So it could be at that 29 30 just gay start with on.
It could be far before.
Could be.
You have a year ago.
It doesn't matter.
You can pick the age.
But what did,
what advice,
if you had to give advice to your younger self or someone just like you,
cause a lot of people like me or like I don't want to step on the butterfly
because I'm pretty happy with where I am.
So I wouldn't give any advice.
But if you had to give some advice to either a younger version of yourself or
does someone who's similarly built?
Yeah,
advice to my younger self is going to be,
you know,
relax man.
It's going to be all right.
That's gonna fucking be all right.
You know,
it's,
it's this crazy thing where like in hindsight,
we can always look backwards and say,
man,
I'm grateful for all that shit.
Like I'm grateful for all of my failures.
But with foresight,
we look at everything that's coming ahead with terror.
This next thing is going to be,
oh,
that's going to be the one that knocks me out.
Oh,
that next deal.
And it's going to be the one that kills me or that next failure that's going to
be devastating.
But always in hindsight,
we're grateful.
So what if we switched our hindsight into foresight and it was like,
oh,
whatever happens,
I'll just be grateful for it later anyways.
And then all of a sudden we're really enjoying ourselves,
you know?
And I was terrible at that.
The first few years I started on it,
I was petrified that it was going to fail because I was so attached to its
success.
I'm finally doing it.
It's gonna fail.
I'm gonna ruin it,
you know?
And I didn't enjoy it.
And it didn't really enjoy those initial formative years like I could have and
you know,
so in almost every age and almost every year it would be relaxed man.
Trust,
like trust,
whatever happens,
you'll figure out a way you'll be better,
stronger,
faster,
you know,
wiser for it.
So be grateful for it in advance,
dig it,
dig it.
And where can people say hi on the Internet,
learn more about what you're up to,
where would you like people to check you out,
your projects and so on?
Yeah,
I think I,
you know,
Instagram is probably my most active,
I post to all the social platforms but it's just at Aubrey Marcus on Instagram
and I curate all those posts myself and it's a good wide variety of me doing
weird stuff in the gym and me posting spiritual quotes in different ideas.
And I actually look forward to those times where I get sideswiped by the
universe cause I always have some Pearl I can come and I generally put that out
on Instagram or a podcast.
And then of course my podcast to the Aubrey Marcus podcast.
That's a great place to listen to me.
Have some cool conversations with people.
Perfect.
And I will link to all of that in the show notes for folks as usual.
Tim.
Dot.
Blog forward slash podcast for all of the links,
resources,
books,
and so on that we've discussed.
A good to hang man.
Yeah,
man.
I'll go.
I'll go under over.
There we go.
We're still figuring out the set up here with the wires.
None of that is,
that is my fault.
I'll take all the blame slash coach the gun under
a,
it's okay.
Next time.
How's your father?
Uh,
you know,
there's a,
there's,
I had a friend who was a,
grew up in a cannibal tribe and that was the traditional,
yeah,
that was a tradition is a famous author by the way.
Yeah.
And that was the traditional greeting.
They would grab each other's genitals and give them,
they would tell them,
you know what?
They'd tell them,
no,
I would eat your feces.
Wow.
That was the Greek.
Grab someone's genitals and say,
oh,
your feces.
I hear that's the new thing to do in Brooklyn.
Hipster way to do it guys.
So feel free to take that,
by the way,
0.01% people who listen to this podcast and take everything literally.
That's true.
Please don't do that.
You might get shot in the face.
No,
that's not allowed.
I Aubrey,
always fun to hang,
man.
Thanks Greg.
Great time.
Thanks for [inaudible] and to everybody listening,
as always.
Until next time,
thank you for listening.
Be Safe out there and don't forget six breaths.
Talk to you soon.